[Music]
a three-story building is about 10 m
tall six times bigger than you in the
opposite direction six times smaller
than you you get things like a cute
squirrel about 27 CM small so the
building is just as big relative to you
as you are to a squirrel you're in the
middle it's easy to understand in fact
you are in the middle of everything in
the universe let's go on a Fantastical
journey together to the small and the
large and see if it's really
true an A320 is 37 M long the roofer's
hummingbird is around 7 cm both of these
flyers are 23 times bigger or smaller
than you and both fly InterContinental
distances the Tiny Bird migrates between
Alaska and Mexico if the hummingbird
were the same size as the jet it would
circle the Earth 85 times every year
dinon the largest ant in the world is
about 55 times smaller than you their
small colonies have around 100
individuals but no queens instead they
ruthlessly compete for status within the
nest which can reach 1.2 M deep if
humans lived like dapon we'd be building
towers of over 25 stories filled with
offices and ruthlessly competing for
status and
wait the deadliest and most annoying
insect in the world is the mosquito 235
times smaller than you while on the
other end the Empire State Building is
about that much larger than you kind of
unimaginable how something this small
creates so much Devastation for
something that big we're getting to the
borders of human perception now like
coarse grains of sand about 3 mm 550
times smaller than you you can feel
their shape and roughness between your
fingers and if you focus see them
individually we mix them into concrete
that can hold up the the tallest towers
ever built like the 828 M tall Burge
Khalifa that's 500 times larger than you
if you were that tall people would be as
small to you as grains of sand in your
hand hey be gentle anything smaller or
bigger and it becomes hard to grasp a
mediumsized city like Lisbon is about
6,000 times larger than yourself and
permeated by a network of Highways roads
and alleys on the other end about 6,00
times smaller than you are your small
arteries permeating your whole body
actually you're in the middle between
your network of blood vessels and the
network of a city like Lisbon if you
think of a city as a living being you
find more and more parallels a small
alley is as small to the city as an
arterial 0.1 mm wide is to you your
tiniest capillaries are to you what the
pipes bringing water to homes are to
Lisbon going further 100,000 times
smaller than than you we reach a typical
skin cell about 30 microm in diameter a
neutr is half as big and one of your red
blood cells is mely 7 microm they are as
small to you as you are to the entire
Tokyo metropolitan area the largest
urban area in the world spanning over
160 km you are so incredibly big filled
with so much complexity so many
different moving parts or are you just a
cell in the human civilization super
structure are are you both our steps are
getting larger and larger now Germany is
around 875 km from north to south and
the fourth biggest agricultural exporter
in the world ryia is a nitrogen fixing
bacteria up to 3 micromet long and
without it that sort of agricultural
production is impossible so we have a
country and a bacterium depending on
each other and you are in the middle
both being roughly 550,000 times larger
or smaller than you what about the whole
earth it's about 12,700 km in diameter
about 7.7 billion times larger than you
on the other side of the scale is corny
bacteria as little as 0.3 micromet
across living on your skin and eyes
along with 100 billion other bacteria
more than 10 times more than there are
humans on Earth again you're in the
center right in the middle of something
so large that our civilization is a mere
scratch on its surface and something so
small and numerous you never notice its
presence even as it touches you does
that make you feel small or big from
here on out your brain is breaking a bit
four times wider than Earth is Neptune a
cold blue gas giant
49,500 km wide the largest planet though
is Jupiter 140,000 km in diameter a
Titanic Abyss shrouded in terrible winds
you could drop Earth hole in into its
depths and it would simply vanish on the
opposite scale we find the deadly West
Nile Virus 50 NM in diameter or one step
down the spike proteins on a Corona
virus that open up cells for its RNA
payload they are as small to you as you
are to the planet Jupiter you are in the
middle between gigantic planets and the
world of viruses these tiny things so
deadly let that sink in a tiny virus is
taking over and killing lung cells up to
500 times larger than itself with the
help of a tiny protein weapon that's
like you trying to kill a giant the size
of the Burge Khalifa with a
screwdriver but the real boss of the
solar system is the sun 10 times bigger
than Jupiter a billion times larger than
you controlling all the planets and
source of all energy that drives life a
billion times smaller than you you
clearly the boss of our body is a DNA
strand containing all the information
making your life possible you're right
in the middle between the most important
factors keeping everything alive from
here on things just kind of stop making
sense a billion is already too much but
now everything just seems to mean a lot
the super massive black hole at the
center of our galaxy Sagittarius AAR is
14.5 billion times bigger than you a
hydrogen atom is 15.5 billion I times
smaller than you yeah okay sure but the
thing is we're not even close to being
done and it's not impossible to get at
least a sense of how these
scale the solar system is 22 trillion
times larger than you on the other end
of the scale is the wavelength of low
energy neutrinos released from Fusion
reactions in our sun about 100 trillion
of them are passing through you every
single second like ghosts a trillion
times smaller than you basically never
hitting any of the particles inside you
if you moved through the solar system in
a straight line you probably wouldn't
hit anything either although things are
beginning to get really weird now a
single proton at the heart of the
hydrogen atom is almost exactly one
quadrillion times smaller than you if
the proton were as big as you the
hydrogen atoms would be taller than 12
mount
everestsolar is at all the distance to
the closest star to Earth Alpha centu is
not one quadrillion times in the other
direction from the tiny proton but 24
quadrillion space is just so large it's
kind of mean and it goes on like this a
quintilian times smaller than you is the
Strange World of the quarks the proton
is not actually like a tiny Ball but
kind of just a ripple on the surface of
the ocean of
quarks every moment countless quarks pop
into existence along with their
antiparticle enemies before doing
Furious battle and annihilating each
other in an instant how many impossible
to say because the harder you look for
them the more quarks seem to appear
we're simplifying so much it's like a
lie anyway however we choose to
illustrate this it's wrong what actually
is a quark what does it look like to
human Minds nobody knows as you sit here
confused let's look up again the ocean
of quarks and a proton inside a single
atom of a single cell of your body is as
small to you as you are compared to a
sphere around 174 light years across
containing about 16,000 stars and this
is just a tiny Speck of dust to our
galaxy The Milky Way is close to 1
sextilion times larger than you at the
opposite end we have particles a
sextilion times smaller than yourself
like the wavelength of high energy
neutrinos released when cosmic rays hit
our atmosphere we're getting to the end
the observable universe is 93 billion
light years in diameter close to a
billion billion billion human lengths
but it's still finite it's only 465,000
Milky Ways side by side if you were the
size of our galaxy the observable
universe would only be a day drive
across on the other end of that scale we
have the tiniest particle ever detected
a proton traveling so close to the speed
of light it got squished into a pancake
as small compared to you as the whole
observable universe is Big to you we're
at the border of things that we have
evidence for are you truly in the middle
of everything the theoretical smallest
physical distance is the plank length
100 million times smaller than even the
pancake proton but we don't know if it's
real only that our theories of the
universe break down here likewise on the
other end does the bigness of the
universe match the smallness of the
plank length well actually the universe
could be considerably larger than that
but we will never know let's go back and
look at the dimensions
again there are so many big things and
so many small things wrapped up in
them the universe seems to be exactly
the right size with you in the
middle
how do you try to get it exactly right
say when you have to make a big Choice
like buying a new mattress you probably
compare trustworthy reviews and test out
a few models but what if you plan to
spend money on something you can't just
return to the seller and the decision
doesn't just affect your aching back
givewell is an independent and rigorous
resource for a different kind of
purchase a donation give Well's mission
is to let donors make informed decisions
about high impact giving that's why
they've now spent over 15 years
researching charitable organizations and
only direct funding to a few of the
highest impact opportunities they've
found in global health and poverty
alleviation and why we trust their
judgment you can find all of their
research and recommendations on their
site for free over 100,000 donors have
used givewell to donate more than $1
billion these donations have the
potential to save over1 15,000 lives and
improve the lives of millions more if
you've never donated through giveway
well before you can have your donation
match to up to $100 before the end of
the year or as long as matching funds
last donations made through them are tax
deductible and givewell doesn't take a
cut to claim your match go to givewell
dorg pick YouTube and enter cart at
checkout to get your donation
[Music]
matched
thanks to all of you out there for all
the love and support we wish you a
peaceful and cozy turn of the Year see
you back at Full Throttle in
[Music]
January